This is sponsored by Fortnite!
The theme for chapter 6 is Japan themed.
Because there's a lot of like...
The new map itself has like new locations where you're fighting like...
Demons and stuff which looks really cool.
So like they have this new area.
This area there.
Which is like...
They're like mini boss fights.
This is what the boss fight looks like that...
It's so cool.
Where is she?
Yeah, she has a gun.
I'm shooting her.
Frosty, I need you to help.
Okay.
Frosty.
Frosty, where is he?
That's fine.
I'm stuck.
Frosty, I'm stuck!
Okay, nice.
A Night Rose.
And then like...
He's gonna pick her up.
And you gotta shoot the eye.
Oh, wow!
Can I shoot from the back?
Oh.
And then you gotta shoot her from here.
Frosty!
I can't shoot at him!
Oh, I can.
Nevermind.
I can shoot the back.
I didn't realize that.
It's fine, Frosty.
I'm helping.
Shoot her!
Nice, we did it.
Yoink.
What's this?
Oh, no!
This...
This one's really cool.
And then I do that.
And then I go...
Oh, wait.
That's what happens.
It's a portal.
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, that's another boss fight!
We can take him!
Let's get this boss fight.
Oh f- It's okay.
Oh, there's a portal too.
There's too many elemental!
You can return them to their home, but you don't have to do that.
Okay.
Don't worry, we got this.
We got this, Frosty.
Oh my God!
Is he
gonna...
Over here.
No!
I messed up!
I got scared!
No, I couldn't use the...
Elemental.
But like...
Wait, that's sick.
I think like, my favorite one was...
My favorite- Oh my God.
Oh wait, that's not the element.
Oh, it's a sticker!
Oh, that's- She's cute though.
I also really like their original skin too.
Their original skins are really cool as well.
Oh, and then this is the Night Rose!
This is the lady that we eliminated earlier.
Wait, what's this?
Is this like the...
Oh, it's a backpack.
Wait, is this like...
Oh.
The puppet dance.
Yeah, she's the boss girl!
Sorry, what's the last one?
The tactical Night Rose.
I wonder if they have the...
Oh, they're...
Oh, is this the glider?
Oh!
Okay, that's sick.
That's a sick glider though.
Oh my God!
Yes!
Okay, wait, wait.
Oh my God.
Now, I have anime on my side.
Oh my God, this is good.
This is good.
This is good for us.
Like, what am I supposed to do in this situation?
Oh my God.
What am I supposed to...
That's right.
Yeah!
We need to get a better car.
I want a sicker car.
I ask and I receive.
There we go.
Alright, guys.
Come on.
Get in here.
Oh, there's a bike next to me too.
We can be like...
Like a bodyguard in the president.
Fill your shield?
No.
Okay, let me chug jug.
I want a Victory Royale.
That was a cool car earlier.
He ruined it.
He overwrote the trip.
No, he could have just ran.
Oh my God.
You could have ran.
Weak.
I miss.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's still a car!
Bro, no!
I still got him!
No!
It's still a car.
Guys, we're gonna work together, okay?
Guys!
In the spirit of Fortnite Chapter 6, eliminate the boss together.
Somehow, everybody's gonna work together and fight...
Oh my God.
Maybe there's too many people.
And if you don't fight, you're gonna get killed.
If you find a gun, use your fists, okay?
I bet we can melee her.
Guys, I don't even think we need a gun.
Guys, let's all go in and start meleeing.
Let's all go in.
Screw it.
Guys, melee!
God, not me!
Okay, guys, we're gonna work together.
Oh my God!
Alright, we did it, guys!
Look at that.
Zero crowns.
Alright, make a circle.
Make a circle, dragons.
Take your gun out.
Find one person you want to shoot at.
And when I say...
When I shoot my gun, you shoot at that one person that you pick.
That one target you pick.
Alright?
Three.
When I shoot my gun, you shoot at them.
At one target you pick.
Guys.
Oh, I silenced her.
Sorry, that was an accident.
Sorry, I have to go to the other zone now.
I forgot I had to silence her.
Alright.
Alright, everybody.
I need a sacrifice.
Alright, default women.
You know what that means.
You guys had swords this entire time?
No.
How did you win?
You weren't even part of the circle!
You weren't even...
They stole.
Of course they did.
Remember to check out Fortnite chapter 6 now.
You can play it right now.
Yeah, right now.
And it's all free.